I'm someone that I if I feel it I don't
hold back and you stay here you need to
know the repercussions of what is gonna
happen the thing with Hannah Brown and
next week's episode if it comes to an
end how how will the other women really
know you're ready and move on ready to
find love again
I don't know if it ends there you know
um you guys a little tune in to see what
happens there but you'll see it'll all
be explained another upcoming promo you
say I feel like I'm gonna pass out it
was just the last thing I needed to hear
what are you a lot of T's what was so
intense that could make you pass out I'm
just hearing it that um yeah that that
was this entire experience was it was
amazing for me but it was really really
difficult as well and I can say that the
last week of this was the hardest of my
life and you know you guys you this
you're gonna see what happens it's crazy
I couldn't have expected any of that to
go the way it did but I can't say that
I'm very happy with how everything ended
up and it's just I was it was looked
like the last second stuff was going on
and it was hard well with how things
ended with with hannasseys and
everything with jed were you concerned
at all about being deceived did you hope
that production would tell you if they
saw something yes I was first for it yes
but there's a great thing with like
production of you know you don't want to
be in any way like given information or
something you want to be able to
experience it authentically and this is
a real relationship and yes going into I
was I had that fear that possibly made
someone is here for tonight that very
first night I made a very clear point of
asking the woman to show me the respect
that I was showing them letting them
know how much this meant to mean I was
taking it so seriously so please like
don't I mean I know that this can give
you other opportunities I get that I'm
not naive but use it for what it's
intended for and definitely had that
fear but I can say I had a great group
for sure I heard you kissed more women
on one night than we saw air is that
true and if so how many ya think I
kissed 12 the first night and well I'm
not i'm mocchi and i don't know why
people think it's weird I'm dating them
and
I am someone that I if I feel it I don't
hold back and there is a lot of instant
chemistry and connections and you know
wasn't all me some of the girls were
coming up to me kiss me I'm not gonna
trust me out now I'm not making I'm not
yeah there's anything wrong I've seen
people to say like it's weird I'm like
really inside my hearts applauding for
you oh yeah I'm proud of you I was yeah
and you're acting honestly right yeah on
its own with what you feel the moment
exactly I'm not gonna fake it now I'm
gonna have one celebrity contestant on
the show who would you pick to bring on
Miss Charlie's do it why what is it
about her I'm just a huge fan hers and
that was I was so unexpected when she
kind of got that post and I saw light
fixture and then I saw heard she's
already explaining how she would do her
entrances coming out of the limo and
loved it I was all about it I'm like all
right that's a picker
[Music]